what it looks like in biology
is that the rules or the laws depend on
the state
this is typical in computer science this
is obvious to you you know the update
rule depends on the state of the machine
right but
and you know you don't think about um
you know
that being sort of the dynamic in
physics it's you know the rules given to
you and then it
you know it's a very special subclass
say of computations if
you know you don't ever change the
update um
but in biology it seems to be that the
state and the law change
together as a function of time and we
don't have that as a paradigm in physics
um and so a lot of people talked about
this as being kind of a perplexing
feature
that maybe there are certain scenarios
where the laws of physics or the laws
that govern a particular system
actually change the function of the
state of that system
that's trippy so yeah the hope of
physics
it's a hope i guess but often stated as
a
underlying assumption is that the law is
uh static right okay
and even having laws that vary in time
and not even as a function of the state
is very
radical when you the time in general
like yeah
you want to remove time from the
equation as much as possible
yeah i i do um there's some interesting
things in this like
when we think sort of deep more deeply
about the actual physics that we're
trying to propose governs life
um with me with collaborators and then
also other people that think
about similar things that time might
actually be fundamental and there really
is an ordering to time
um and that events in the universe are
unique because they have a particular
you know they they happen like an object
in the universe requires a certain
history of events in order to exist
which therefore suggests that time
really does have an ordering i'm not
talking about the flow of time and our
perception of time just the ordering of
events causation of things
yes causation there's that word again so
causation that's
when you say time you mean causation yes
in your proposed
model of the physics of life
the the fundamental thing would be
causation if you were to bet your money
on one particular horse or whatever yes
and then space is emergent yes so
everything is emergent except
time kind of yeah or causation
change all the time why does it look
like laws are the same laws
well because uh well one way um
and i actually this idea comes from lee
cronin because i work with him very
closely on these things
is that the laws of physics look the way
they do because they're low memory laws
so they don't require a lot of
information to specify them they're very
easy for the universe to implement
but if you get something like me for
example i require 4 billion year history
to exist
in the universe i come with a lot of
historical baggage
and that's part of what i am as a set of
causes that exist in the universe
so i have local rules that apply to me
that are associated with sort of the
information in my history
that aren't universal to every object in
the universe um and there are some
things that are very easily
easy to implement low memory rules that
apply to everything in the universe
so there's no shortcuts to you no i so
yeah i don't believe in like things like
boltzmann brains or
uh you know fluctuations out of the
vacuum that can produce things like your
desk ornaments
um i actually think they require
a particular causal chain of events to
exist
you